A6 yeah so actually one side is getting
checkmated if Magnus finds this move
which is I've got to say incredibly hard
to see
she finds it wow if he finds this move
he's doing the check mating if he found
if he played any other move he would
have been checkmated
wow uh you think you're right this
Knight is coming in now there's also the
idea of some checks there's also the
Black Knight coming to take this Pawn
maybe white can't defend and again we
see the top computer move stop fish
suggest suggesting White's Bishop
dropping back that is incredibly hard
any other move
black wins on the spot essentially and
the first move that came to my mind was
The Rook shuffling across this is the
second best move for stockfish uh
according to stockfish hitting the black
queen the black queen can move though
with a check and uh when the white king
Runs Out The Way which I think it has to
do I think black can keep it simple now
there's still a threat of Checkmate on
the back rank but black can create some
Escape squares taking a knight with
Czech and another check